the las vegas desert gets hit with
another day of snow
families all across southern nevada
heading out to enjoy the gift from
mother nature
it's been really nice i just like going
down the hills and sledding
a beautiful and unique day to remember
in the valley
all of that snow in the northwest valley
made for a great
snow day and snow morning for many
families especially before school
thank you for joining us at six o'clock
i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez yeah brian it
burned off pretty quickly 8 news now
reporter kate houston went to a number
of
parks places like sky canyon the
providence area to see how
families welcome this wintry conditions
gilchrist brothers park was a very
popular spot this morning with snow
covering this entire area now although
much of that is now gone
dozens of families took advantage of it
while they could
starting early this morning families
from the northwest valley flocked to
local parks to enjoy some winter fun
it was snowing over here so we thought
they'd just come down hang out
and show the baby some snow
[Applause]
parents and kids were able to space out
and take part in classic snow activities
dozens of kids were having snowball
fights building snowmen
and sledding down this big hill we
brought a homemade sled
at the top of a container it didn't work
so someone let us borrow a sled so
my four-year-old is out there sledding
right now
nearby huckleberry park was also packed
with families enjoying similar snowy
conditions
many tell me they were surprised to see
just how well the snow was sticking
it's something i've never seen before we
went to colorado a couple months ago
and it was beautiful over there and i
thought okay i'd never be able to see
that again unless we went there again
and it's almost similar to it it's like
how much snow we've got i haven't seen
this much snow in vegas since like the
15 years i've lived here
for some this was their first snow day
parents say it was nice to see their
kids off of a screen
and outside having fun kate houston 8
news now